what's happening reject nation so
apparently there was some spider-man 3
leaked set photos when waiting forever
for some actual set photos to come out
this came out yesterday we weren't
around to cover it so
we're going to check out 3c films video
today he's a huge spider-man fan i've
seen so many of his spider-man videos
we've been talking back and forth on
twitter especially since covering
his video last week so i was like you
know what let's see what he's got in
store as he breaks down these set photos
for us
love you chris
all right big champion game huh parker
[Laughter]
i'm gonna cry hello spiderman fans
what's the hell here it is
currently being filmed in atlanta what
i'm going to be doing here for you guys
is breaking down these
photos concerning spider-man 3 also
taking note of the one major change to
the new suit in spider-man 3.
new suit you say small detail i think
makes the biggest difference as a
spider-man fan
and even some thoughts and theories on
what exactly is going on here so how
many new web heads out there give me
your opinions on these spider-man 3 set
photos what do you think exactly is
going on here what do you think the
location means in spider-man 3 how do
you feel about the setting
and also don't be forgetting to hit that
like button especially if you're
enjoying the spider-man contest there's
more than it really is
these photos are being provided by just
jared they're the ones who haven't owned
these photos so you can check them out
on their website but
we got our first sneak peek of
spider-man 3 of him in costume here now
now when i go ahead and show you these
it really doesn't seem like it's all
that
different like anything has changed it
just seems like the good old spider-man
suit that just looks
100 amazing in my opinion and i still
get so
baffled that disney and sony decide to
look at that suit
how it looks in daylight this is a leak
set photo
from an unprofessional artist and look
how amazing that's
true it looks great still yeah we're
gonna cover that thing in some cgi for
you but either way
as an eagle dice spider-man fan you
should have noticed one major change to
this suit that is different
from the way it looked in spider-man far
from home that i'm like
finally for the ultimate spider-man
movie they are getting
it right the one major change that
they've made to this suit
is they went ahead and removed some of
the black strips
on the belt of this spider-man nope did
not notice
yeah i was like shoulder pads i was like
what's different about this
last recent years but for some reason
they're not allowed to have
this belt in the shape of underwear
surrounding them in modern day i mean
superman's already gotten rid of that
batman's gotten rid of that to an extent
and they were trying to mask that
underwear look in all the spider-man
suits and the spider-man ocd
in me was always flaring up let me take
you back
to the days when they introduced good
old andrew garfield is spider-man
this is before ya boy had a youtube
channel and a great community of you
spiderman fans following me around and
making cringy intros no i was sitting at
high school at the computer lab just
staring at this thing and all i could
think about is
why the hell are they not connecting the
lines
you don't know how much higher on the
list this suit would be as my top
favorite suits
if those lines at the bottom just
happened to me and also if they got
those yellow weird eyes that they gave
him just make those silver or white
please
now if finally being shown off and proud
this spell
i think it makes the suit just look a
lot more cleaner
a little more simple in a good way the
other thing to notice here is the emblem
is also highlighted that's where i
noticed it was the emblem
yeah the biggest major changes right now
but like i said to me
they make a world of difference if you
didn't even notice them when i pulled up
this photo and we're going
what are you talking about new suit well
then i guess you're fine with that belt
being hidden you monster but if you
are wanting a brand new looking soup it
looks like we're gonna get one because
we have here an instagram user who
prefers to remain anonymous but this
person was the one who was letting us
know hey guys you're about to get some
spider-man three set photos pretty soon
so be on the lookout
and he's also been following a new one
super closely
and this person being around the set of
spider-man 3 a lot he has went ahead and
said this replying to somebody else i
wouldn't call that new before
just a small update i'm sure the new one
is going to be very different and then
he goes ahead and responds
saying it is new and there is another
one
can't do an mcu spider-man without
another one
spider-man far from home suit was just
going to be something that the movie
would ignore and it's like oh we just
got rid of those details a little bit
we're not really going to talk about
how or why i can change this well right
here with him saying it no this
is a new suit does that mean we're gonna
get a moment where the previous suit
needs to be
gotten rid of whether to some battle
damage or spiderman just is always
updating this thing like it's in ios
unless they give us a brand new suit
halfway into the movie or
towards the end hold on it's like we
gotta talk a little bit about this
before we move forward
this updated look all right i didn't
notice i can't [ __ ] you guy
obviously i did it the thing i was i was
like is the shoulder pads the emblem
definitely looked
a lot more defined that was something i
was like when i was doing this i was
referring to that
um and i suppose for like the hardcore
spider fans just such as yourself chris
that
the belt thing would be something that
would stand out to you be very important
and it's true like the whole underwear
look is something that we have
really steered clear from yeah
points that's something i haven't
thought about but yeah we definitely try
to avoid that because i think there's
something that's
inherently been considered kind of goofy
yeah
almost yeah and i i am kind of curious
though
if they would acknowledge it i i can see
there being a scenario where
they don't acknowledge it where they
just like let the movie play out it's
just a little bit of an updated look
it's common in superhero movie cinema
that they'll do that they don't always
have to talk about it but i think with
as much
emphasis as there has been on i think it
was actually around the dark night time
when
they really made emphasis on suit
changes no matter what it was as simple
as i want to be able to turn my head
from the dark knight
and especially with spider-man you know
like i think with iron man and
spider-man there tends to be
acknowledgement
of whenever they're updating the suits
and especially with spiderman
as you can see from far from home that
if you're gonna do
any little modification even that little
strip with the belt
i think you can especially with how
attention to detail we are with canon
with mcu that you gotta
kind of acknowledge it a little bit even
if it's
a little something but when would he
have time to do it in the middle of
being a fugitive on the right yeah
yeah i i mean you know i'm sure if that
is the point that is the plot yeah
kind of clandestine way to access maybe
the suit making machine again or
whatever but that is
that is a funny point because uh yeah i
mean i never would have even
uh picked it up like it's one of those
things that like so subtle it's so
subtle and yet
now that i am looking at it i'm going to
look at it in every spider-man costume
no i'm not going to not notice i'm not
going to die notice that yeah and it's
the kind of thing where i feel like yeah
you could very easily go it's a small
detail
we're going back a little bit more
traditional but we don't need to make a
deal out of it at the same time though
i mean the mcu has gotten to where it is
and and has
at least a better continuity than a lot
of
other franchises do doing so i've said
spider-man homecoming with its
time ears or whatever that eight or five
forget
which one they got wrong yeah isn't it i
think it's like actually eight or six
yeah but yeah
i mean and especially with that existing
meme i would almost feel like the onus
would be on them just to either
acknowledge it or to create a scenario
where it's clear that it's long enough
after that okay maybe he got a new scene
and that canon
that is a great photo without having any
cgi altercations at all it's just
clear because a lot of times the suits
don't look as great unless you
finally do your post digital photography
touch-ups and stuff and your
your coloring effects and all that but
that looks great looks like he decided
to pose for this picture
it's just jared over there damage or
spider-man just is always
updating this thing like it's in ios and
of course it's not a marvel mcu movie
unless they give us a brand new suit
more towards the end and i'm kind of
disappointed by that man because
i super love the red and black suit i
know some people like the traditional
red and blue which i completely respect
too but there's something about this
red and black suit that really pops for
me especially if we're getting
all three spider-man coming together tom
holland's really going to be able to
stand
out in that crowd which also makes me
wonder what kind of suit they're going
to give andrew garfield whether they're
going to give him
his amazing spider-man 2 suit or maybe a
better updated version of that amazing
spider-man suit that he first got which
i wouldn't mind like i said just make
that belt touch and have
a nice turn take your guesses now for
what exactly
i love them i don't know if it's the
characters talk about that spider suit
i think again it's just gonna be
something simple and sleek down for all
we know
this hint of another suit could just be
sort of like a night monkey situation
where
because everybody is after spider-man in
town he can't really risk going out in
his regular
suit because everyone will recognize
that so he has to put on an undercover
suit or some kind of homemade suit again
because he's not able to get to his lab
or i should say stark industries left
but as far as what's actually going on
in these photos
it's really resembling toby mcguire when
he's dancing in spider-man 3.
i highly doubt that's actually what he's
doing here but hey if this version of
peter parker decides to bust out that
dance i ain't gonna say a thing about it
two really interesting things to note
i would really like i just want to say i
would love it if they pay homage then
i i want bully mcguire i think they
should pay homage to that please
absolutely and if we're talking to you
about andrew garfield
uh coming back for this spider-man movie
i'd want him to have the amazing
spider-man suit you know
it has to be that it can't be some i
think it'd be cool if you kept it with
the suits that we remember
the same thing with toby maguire even if
they are aged or it takes place in the
future for those characters in their
timeline
i just think for a nostalgia factor it'd
be cool to just have them come back
yeah battle warren that's actually what
he's doing here but hey if this version
of peter parker decides to bust out that
dance i ain't gonna say a thing about it
two really interesting things to note
though about this location and where
they're filming one
the main setting for this shoe right
here is the christmas time huh by the
name of peter pan now i went ahead and
made a little joke once i saw these
photos and i was like
what is peter parker that bakery shop is
actually the key
to the multiverse in spider-man 3. the
way i came to that conclusion is
you know peter wonderland
[Music]
peter pan goes to neverland so peter
parker entering neverland yeah
i know it sounds ridiculous but i mean
this is awesome oh really
ridiculous nick fury lost his eye to an
alien cat so
anything can happen really one thing
also that hey it's tom allen's brother
hey look at that family day
bring your folks to work today i only
want to pause brief but he's got wires
i'm sure he'll talk about he's got wires
attached to him she's he's in the movie
i guess we'll get time we really let the
video play out but
um i gotta say chris i think your um
your theory about
that is actually not that's not
far-fetched you're saying it sounds
ridiculous
but i think in terms of what neverland
is or presents itself
calling it peter pan peter parker the
pee pees are similar
i just said we're pee pee similar pay
pays yep that's kind of humor you're
gonna get here at the real rejects
3p uh i think that the idea of it in
in terms of like references actually
isn't far off or that's i don't think
it's that silly yeah i think it actually
works man oh yeah it works in the magic
of their universe the second you started
saying something i'm like my mind
started going there before i even said
anything so i was like wait a minute no
you might
think you're onto something all right
guys so actually in the middle of
slicing and dicing this video super
duper quick discovered some other photos
that i didn't know about
where zendaya is on set and she's
actually in that peter pan
shop it could just be that in this scene
peter parker is gonna go visit michelle
at the new place she's working at
during the holidays like maybe she's
working there to just get some money
to buy some presents you know how some
high school students will do that during
the holidays
i could see that just being the the
actual possibility i like chris's theory
but
i think this is probably more likely you
got this other photo here
of tom haldon and i can't tell if this
is tom holland talking with someone on
set
or if he's kind of doing that peter
parker thing in spider-man 2 with toby
mcguire where he's like rehearsing a
poem or something something to
say to michelle either way and it's kind
of cool to know that actually
zendaya's character michelle is working
in that shop it's important to point out
had to make sure they're included here
one thing also that is really puzzling
fans and making them wonder like what is
going on here
is we have tom hanks harry harry harry
holland yeah
so it seems that even tom holland's
brother has a role in
spider-man three man we thought this
movie was packed already
this is kind of just a cameo he's an
alternate peter
as you know he loves his brother a lot
and is always bringing him in for his
videos so it's kind of cool that he'll
also be popping up in spider-man 3 as a
small cameo
a lot of people though are theorizing to
what exactly is going on some of the
popular theories goes as
maybe this is going to be a flashback
scene and we'll finally see what's
happening to that faithful night where
peter parker lost
uncle ben maybe they'll finally flesh
out that story so we can connect
and we can sympathize when we meet all
these other spiders i don't think that's
true
now is the time for an i think tom
holland already looks young enough or if
you put a little bit of makeup on
youtube they did it to the stranger
things kids
i can't get any confirmation on that
this might be from a different movie
guys but
everyone is going around and saying it's
from the set of spider-man 3. if you do
know it's from a different movie please
let me know down below but i think in
this photo tom holland definitely looks
younger just by a little bit of a hair
change but my best guess to what's
actually going on here is that it's said
that this scene being filmed for
spider-man 3
is just stopping a regular thief in new
york city who's taking maybe another
perk
we gotta talk a little bit about
remember this mart 815 all right
i think this is i don't think it would
be a flashback
of where he's playing what chris is
saying is that the theory is that there
he'd be playing a young
version of tom holland seeing the uncle
ben origins yes
i don't think that's the case i think by
this point with the amount of
de-aging mcu has done themselves
they would just do that with tom holland
he's not that far off from the time when
uncle ben
like especially the way he just
naturally looks how he has such a young
look about him
they would just de-age him and if they
were to do it like this
i don't know that would be like nepotism
at its finest would it not be
i feel like it has like a little cameo
or something is one thing but to give
him such like a
main storyline point like a come on guys
i feel like that would ultimately
distract from what the point of that
scene would be like if you're going back
to the most heartbreaking
core wound of peter parker's life i
don't think you want to distract fans
with like hey it's a surprise
yeah it becomes like a meme i'm sure
it's just some like fun little cameo
moment i don't think it's actually
something that's that like oh a big deal
my money's on an alternate peter for for
laughs or it could be
yeah it could be another alternate peter
in the many dimension hopping and he
just kind of looks like tom hall you
know like i think it will work
or maybe he has a brother in another
universe you know something like that
or you know yeah i i don't think it has
to be
some yeah i don't know i just think
that's a little too far-fetched
sir biker since it's the front of this
bakery shop maybe stealing someone's
donut and that could just be the little
cameo role that his brother plays is a
thief
who gets wired up by spider-man as we
see here with tom holland wearing his
mask and then someone in wires
floating up in the air that could be
harry's stun double and that might be
what's going on here but
a lot of people are all saying what if
he's actually playing harry osborne
harry holden
harry osborne no and it's impossible
as our first couple of set photos for
spider-man 3. i think it's really
amazing we just got to keep our eyes
amazing they reveal anything else
they're going to show some jamie foxx
electro out there allow for molina dr
octopus or
if the actual spider people started
showing up toby maguire and andrew
garfield
which i highly doubt it there's no way
they would risk
filming all that stuff in public for it
to get leaked and talked about by
doofuses like me be sure you guys know
your thoughts and theories down below on
these photos do you like them do you
like the little tweak to the suit are
you still
not up for the red and black i know
people want red and blue back and then
everything go ahead and leave your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
and subscribe
follow me on twitter at 3c film review
as always i'm chris
take care awesome thanks chris
i mean i think to to answer your
question really quick chris i think
that it would be cool to get to a point
where we do get the blue back
for this installment it's not a big deal
to me i think that keeping it black
would actually help with
distinguishing him from the other
spider-man presuming i mean it seems
like it's a 99.9
chance that they will be showing up in
here but if they are in indeed showing
up in this movie i think it helps with
distinguishing so i'm on board with you
there
however i do think as time goes on and
the more tom holland is in the
spider-man movies getting the red and
blue
the traditional spider-man look would be
pretty pretty cool to just get to that
point anywho
guys do these set photos excite you
what'd you guys think did you notice
that
i didn't notice the belt i i feel i feel
like i should have been at this point
yeah
true fan of spiderman notice that leave
your thoughts down below subscribe to 3c
films if you haven't done so already
this guy's been
killing it on youtube as of late i've
talked back and forth with him a lot in
twitter messages as of late he already
comes across
nice here but he's even nicer from
getting to talk to him much love to
everyone subscribe click that
notification bell hit the like button
and last but not least peach
i want to shout out my man named jean
jeter gene jeter sent us both over
a copy of his book the craigslist model
and i actually read the whole thing
cover to cover yesterday it was a
wonderful book it's structured
interestingly and it plays out like a
conversation
over instant messenger so it's there's a
bit of a play structure
to it and it's all revolving around the
death of a model that someone
photographed and there's this whole
history there and it's an interesting
back and forth die he didn't ask me
to promote this or plug it he's been
supporting our channel for such a long
time he's been part of our patreon page
for such a long time that when he sent
over this book i was like you know what
i should make the time to read it i read
it in one sitting
this is a quick read an easy read and so
guys you can get this it's available on
amazon put links in the description box
for it it's called the craigslist model
really easy and actually really
interesting reads throughout so
thank you so much for sending this over
did you read it yet i haven't but i'm
going to read it all tonight
looks like someone cares more about gene
you know
gene i love you and i just closed the
year off with your 2020 calendar
so make it 2021 you're done you're done